Matthew Stafford clearly one of the
toughest quarterbacks in the National
Football League finding a way to play
through injury finding a way to play for
adversity finding a way to show up every
week and suit up and play and I say it
all the time
to be a true franchise quarterback
you've got to be able to play so who are
the toughest quarterbacks right now in
the National Football League we put the
question out on Twitter there's already
a bunch of responses but Chris which
guys jump out at you
gosh I mean it's first off I mean Tom
Brady he's up there I mean I mean I've
never I mean a guy at his age he just
stands in the pocket never really had
any fear within the pocket he will
always be up there now he's had some
good pass protection and a good offense
around them but I mean his ability to
compete and talk crap to defensive
linemen when they do hit them and you
know just the the ability to phase it
out I'm always gonna put him in that
conversation I mean he's he's towards
the top of the list with me you know
along with Robby Andrew Luck and Phillip
Rivers Cam Newton those those those four
to me I think were the first ones that
really popped up into my brain Mike yeah
and you know with Tom Brady whatever
he's doing all that pliability avocado
ice cream stuff yeah you know we can
scoff at it but it's clearly working
right I mean he turns 42 in less than
two months and he has shown no signs of
slowing down he can still throw it he
can still move in the pocket now he's
never a guy who's gonna take off and and
sprint down the field and and he's not
gonna be a guy who's gonna go you know
run a pass route and catch it but he has
the agility necessary to step up in the
pocket to slide around to create that
actual space right so he can deliver a
throw to an open receiver but whatever
he does I if I was a quarterback trying
to extend my career I would I would be
standing at the front door of the
nearest T b12 facility banging on it
saying please teach me what I have to do
to play into my forties because whatever
Brady's doing it works and he definitely
takes hits right but he's able to keep
going and remember he talked last week
about recovery how important recovery is
that if you don't know how to recover
six games is too long of a season
because he seems to be on
the idea of 18 because in his mind he
can recover from anything so whatever
he's doing it's working and I think once
he retires maybe that's when his secrets
will be made available to a broader
range of quarterback lest any of them
end up challenging the the total number
of championships he exits the game with
yeah that's right then he's not gonna
give them any secrets but yeah yeah I
mean one of the things I look at for
toughness of a quarterback is their you
know their ability to hang in the pocket
and keep their eyes down the field no
matter what's going on around them and
that's where I respect Tom Brady that's
where I respect Andrew Luck it's where I
respect Cam Newton you know it Philip
Rivers the same way it just doesn't
matter Oh Fletcher Cox is about to hit
me from the back big deal I'm gonna sit
in here and just I got a guy open 15
yards down in the middle of the field
coach is gonna yell at me tomorrow cuz
he's open yep I know I'm gonna take the
hit but so be it you know so that's
where his beauty is and hey another guy
we got a throne in that conversation is
dak Prescott I mean dak Prescott might
be the toughest quarterback in the NFL
right now as a 48 starts game plays a
physical style a football I mean we saw
a few runs last year whether it was
Seattle in the playoffs or the Rams
playoff games here's the Jaguars game
where I just want to go hmm I don't know
if any quarterback would have survived
some of the car crash hits he had other
than Cam Newton so you know that's
that's what kind of guy I look at with
dak Prescott and now that I'm sitting
here watching highlights of dak Prescott
we just showed the Houston Texans then
we got a pup
deshaun Watson DeSean Watson's been a
damn hitting dummy his first few years
in the NFL and he still hangs in there
too so they're all tough we know that
they are all tough but yes some are just
a little bit better about blocking the
noise out than the others
remember Prescott there was a game was
it last year or the year before where he
got hit on the hand and it's like
swelled up like the old cartoon when you
blow into your thumb and it turns into a
giant balloon I mean his hand was a mess
he just kept going he does not miss a
beat and DeSean Watson's been banging
around member the ACL tear he told us at
the Super Bowl after his rookie season
that that had happened during that
Seahawks game and it just went during
practice but that's when he injured it
so you know he keeps going and it's that
ability to operate Chris and this is
what's always impressed me
you are at the center of a storm before
the snap right you've got a process
everything that's happening what is the
defense doing what are your guys doing
do your offensive linemen know what the
hell they're supposed to do do your
receivers know what they're supposed to
do and it's loud and it's hostile if
you're playing on the road and weather
can be a factor and you've got the
defensive linemen shouting profanities
at you and then you get the ball and all
hell breaks loose and you're the guy
that's in the middle of it all right
trying to figure out where's my first
receiver what's my first receiver
where's he did somebody move and and
there's somebody gonna cut off that Lane
is hello but okay
well now I got to move to my second guy
and now where's he was he he's covered
now I gotta move my third guy maybe
gonna look back at my first guy and
meanwhile you're hoping that your
blockers are blocking you're hoping that
your running back picks up a Blitzer
you're trying to apply that sixth sense
because somebody's gonna eventually loop
around and cave you in from behind right
it's amazing it's amazing that people
can do it for one play much less one
game much less a full season and not
miss a beat it's crazy
and you know when I got done on that
career I think I you know you start to
realize that's crazier than you realize
when you're actually in it you know just
to think about it and now I watch
football and then you know standing on
sidelines and certain games I'm just
like oh gosh I mean how these guys
hanging in there you know my my
perception of it is so much different
now that I've been out of the game for
so long and haven't been hit but you're
right and Mike it's one of the big
arguments I always make about you know
ooh do we play the quarterback or do we
sit them the young guy and I always say
you know I always err on the side of
playing because you can't emulate some
of this stuff you just said I don't care
how hard you try and practice but until
Khalil Mac or you know you know bond
Mildura are coming off the edge and
truly trying to rip your head off you
can't really emulate that situation as
far as being in the stadium 70,000
people and the intensity of the offense
and defensive line and that's what does
make the the position special I always
said Mike it's like a for me I don't
know Tom Brady's probably seeing a
slow-motion movie picture for me I saw a
leg you get snippets little pictures
right oh I saw the coverage oh gosh now
when somebody got in my eye oh I saw the
receiver in this window and saw the
safety a little bit and it's really just
about pacing and piecing together a
bunch of frame by frame pictures and
making decisions that way and that's
that's what the great quarterback
can do and when you play 20 years it
gets easier yeah it shows down you get
to that sweet spot in your mid-30s where
it really does you develop a master of
it and yeah I'm looking at some of these
names whether it's Eli Manning Russell
Wilson Ben Roethlisberger yeah Philip
Rivers they're all tough yes I think I
think it's easier to identify the ones
who aren't and you know what I think
it's a very short list I think they're
all tough yeah that's the bottom line
yes to play that position you have got
to be a tough tough guy
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports